The purest form of gold is, of course, golden
and is referred to as 24 karat gold.
Pure gold is much too soft for use in jewelry
and can even be dented by simply pressing
your fingernail hard against it.
Needless to say, daily wear, particularly
for things like rings and bracelets, would
see such jewelry bent and deformed quite quickly.
So the gold must be made more durable by mixing
it with another kind of metal or metals, creating
a gold alloy.
As far as terminology goes, the 24 karats
that make up pure gold translate to all twenty-four
parts being gold.
So an 18 karat gold ring is constructed of
18 parts pure gold and 6 parts something else,
adding up to a total of 24 (75% gold, 25%
other).
The same formula can be applied to any karat
of gold jewelry, such as a 14 karat gold pendant-
made up of 14 parts gold and 10 parts other
metals.
So what are these other metals?
If the desired result for a particular piece
of jewelry is still a golden color, common
metals mixed with gold include copper and
zinc.
With white gold, the jeweler typically uses
metals like silver, palladium, manganese,
and nickel, with nickel for a time being the
main bleaching agent due to its cheapness.
However, nickel has fallen out of favor in
some jewelry circles because it more commonly
causes allergic reactions.
All that said, while the resulting piece in
these cases will be bleached to more of a
silvery color, it doesn’t typically produce
the vibrant silver hue commonly associated
with white gold today.
(Although, there are methods to achieve this
that have been very recently developed.)
But for the vast majority of white gold out
there, the vibrant silver color is created
by coating the white gold alloy with a thin
layer of rhodium, a metal in the platinum
family.
The choice of rhodium comes from its bright
white color along with its extreme durability.
Eventually, though, it will wear down, at
which point it will reveal the yellow tint
of the white gold beneath.
Depending on the exact makeup of the white
gold, this may be barely noticeable to extremely
apparent.
With unscrupulous jewelers, they may even
simply use regular yellow gold alloys plated
with rhodium in their “white gold” as
a way to save a little money in production.
The buyers would have no idea until the rhodium
wore off, which takes a while.
Whatever the case, if you notice a yellow
tint after a while, simply having the white
gold cleaned then having a jeweler apply a
new coating of rhodium returns the metal to
its previous silvery shine, and usually is
relatively inexpensive to have done.
While yellow gold and white gold tend to be
the most common in jewelry, other colors can
be made by adding different metals to the
gold.
For instance, pink and rose gold is made by
adding a higher ratio of copper, with the
amount of copper added determining the hue.
Green gold can be created by adding silver,
copper, and zinc alloys.
Even a black color can be achieved by coating
white gold with a black rhodium.